working with energy
now working with energy
the the biggest problem i see nowadays
and i don't think it's something that i
can correct
because i try to correct it and i have
done for years
but the students choose not to
not to do it so therefore they i can't
see how we can correct it
we've moved on a long way since the days
where the sensei would either slap the
student hit the student shout that the
student make them feel inferior
you know belittle them
these things have had to change because
we're we're in the
modern world now and i don't think it's
necessary yes it was necessary in my
time because my mindset was
of a different era i hope that
i've
progressed even though i've got older
my mind is still vibrant and thinking we
must change we must look at what the
people want today not
what it wanted in my era
so talking about
how do we use energy
within the realms of aikido
so you're on the mat
and um
you you offer let's say you offer a
hi-hat me
my right hand there i am
as you offer your hand
feel you can feel a sort of if you don't
slow enough you can feel ascribing
you could as you do this
in tai chi if we move our hands slowly
we can actually feel the hand going past
the energy of the air
or it might be
the energy of our aura expanding
certain cameras can see this
so
as you offer your hand towards your
partner to grab it
for you to be able to sense this
delicate
feeling and
understanding
you need to be in a state of mind
wanting to sense this
as they start to come to you and they
may start putting their hand out you
need to sense their energy there or
whatever you want to call it
as it's starting to come out
as you get better
just by
standing there and looking at who your
okay is
with
the vision of not staring but seeing
everything
your senses will tell you what that
person is like
and i believe
that going on from my other
talks on energy
i believe that i know that person
not inside out
but it's almost like
you you know
that person
and at that moment in time so you're
you're very much as eckhart tolle would
say
you're very much in the nail
you put but there's more to just do it
putting your hand out to carry out a
shianagi kodakage tension aggie whatever
technique you're going to do
it's that initial
meeting
of you of setting itself up so on the
titanic we is it it's all staged isn't
it so you bow to your partner you you
stand in the right place the distance is
whatever it is
if it's your turn to go first you put
your arm out
and they come to grab your wrist
if it doesn't work out you say can i do
that again
um and this could go on a few times
or if you're in a strict club they might
say you only do two whether you want to
do more or not you can't
so let me go and tell you about
those people who say i'm not into this
energy rubbish i'm just i just love my
keto i have a great time
we all
have the ability
without
knowing how you tie the two together so
i'm talking what i'm talking about is
exactly the same as what i'm going to
talk about now that is
when you meet somebody for the first
time you instantly know before shaking
hands or anything you instantly know
if you're going to like them or not
you're so this
me knowing
my
okay
my attacker or whatever by instantly
knowing them
you can sense
and the higher your senses go in a real
situation
you can sort of like feel their
positiveness they're getting perhaps
bigger because they're feeling
like they're going to win this you know
they're expanding
so
rather than you
reducing
you can read
[Music]
what they are doing what their expansion
is
so as they come to you in a real
situation your instincts will work
and this is the same instincts
whether you know or not but we need the
techniques to carry out
a good escape or a good pin or something
that's where the technical comes in
but as i'm talking about energy
you already know that person if you've
worked on
trying to fine-tune your
your tuition your gut feeling your
sensing
different words all mean the same
so
sometimes
a friend
that you like you know perhaps a student
even that you really like they will
bring a student along
of one of theirs let's say they're a
teacher let me switch it a bit they say
they're a teacher and they're bringing
along to me a new student hasn't met me
before
before they even shake my hand or bow
i will know
if they're feeling
that i'm this big powerful sensei and
they're this little weak person and
they're sort of humbly bowing to me
[Music]
where
i've already got this authority of
much bigger being a much bigger energy
than them
without me even
wanting to portray anything
it's the
stories that their senses told them
about me or they might have watched a
dynamic film
and thought wow you know so as soon as
they meet me they think
i'm this massive person
i i used to think this is cytoscenci but
the thing is he was this massive person
even though he's much smaller than me
unless he stood next to me with his
little braces on and
working clothes and his straw hat
i didn't see him as anything but this
giant of a person who
the last thing you want to do is say
anything wrong do anything wrong
um
strange and yet he was
jovial
love he would laugh
if he thought it was funny laugh more
than most people
anyhow going back to the energy side
we're using it every day if you meet
someone in business you meet somebody in
a cafe
you know they bring a friend along you
meet them you will automatically know
this person
not in don't take the sense of
how well you know them
but you'll you'll know them enough to
know whether
you like the person or not instantly or
not
i shouldn't really put too much emphasis
on whether you like them or not because
i've found people that are very reserved
and you don't can't really read them
and then when you get to know them
they're really nice people
but then you'll get other people who
i have the same thing with
but i'm always aware of them i'm always
thinking they seem okay and i like them
but there's something in the back of my
mind that keeps sort of edging away at
me saying
i wonder if i'm seeing them 100 as they
are or whether they're only showing me
what they want to show me
are they not such a great person
truthfully
so
so as i speak you'll know exactly what
i'm talking about
so why
put off
um
studying it on the mat
once you know the techniques
let's say
you don't feel like you're high enough
yet to be able to study this
but there's a
i have me
code guys that you really like and you
pretty much think you've got it as good
as you can get it
at your level
so why not then add this ingredient in
add it in like the drops of
vanilla essence or something to a cake
they might only be drops
but you're adding them into your overall
practice
now going back to what i try to do with
the classroom teaching and what the
student choose not to do
is talking
when i
in my days when we were shouted out
beaten
bullied all the all the things that i'm
saying
are wrong in this day and age
we were actually too fine to talk
yes i was an adult i run a multi-million
pound business bringing up a family
but i was also
frightened
i don't know fine as the word dubious
but the senseis
with what warth they could come down on
you
with
because
they were so good they could do so
we thought miracles
um
that we didn't speak we just trained
hard and took all our time to
get our breath really because
the training was quite fast a lot faster
than perhaps it is today
and pounding into the map you would
perhaps have four goals
get straight up they would have four
goes
they would get up until they sense they
stopped the class to go to the next
technique or point something out
it was just a mass of uh training
the the conversation was so short you
may you may slip in can i do that again
but normally they were wasted can i do
it again because you'd repeat exactly
the same thing over
rather than
give it a little breather to think
what am i doing wrong perhaps if i go
slower
and cytosines he taught us this where a
lot of the western teachers didn't
not the japanese teacher did
either
so
you have to not
talk and you have to get in the zone
of what
not only technique but switching on your
senses
when i put my arm out can i sense the
feeling that i get from my own
self
this is moving energy
moving your energy
from you out
if if the energy is
portrayed big enough that's why the
great senses have this expanded aura
and after you've got
comfortable with those senses
you can see their glow
just because
you love them so much that you you know
admire them so much
you you you want to absorb everything
they've got to tell you
now this takes me back to most people
have said bruce lee and enter the dragon
when he's doing the
class with the young boy
and he hits him and he says
don't think feel
well
feeling
i used to say a lot
when you do this feel the energy
and you sort of can feel it but really
it is more sensing so if you can work on
these two words feeling and sensing
they'll become the same you know move my
finger i can feel it even in front of
the camera i can feel the energy as i
move you can say you're feeling the
density of the air whatever you want it
to be
to appease you
then please accept it
yes he hit him and said don't think
feel
and that's my gift to you if it's a gift
to tell you
if you really want to advance in aikido
you need to not talk
and when you do talk
use it as a red light flash up to you
and say oh yeah i'm doing it again
i'm not going to talk and if the person
starts talking to you
it may seem ignorant but you don't
always have to
talk back to them
you don't have to get a conversation
why does this annoy me so much it's
because you're missing a valuable part
in your studies
such a valuable part
anyhow thank you for listening i hope
this all helps
and
i hope today i've
told you that technical and mental
should be used as one
and i'm trying to slowly give you more
ideas and keys to open more doors
for your journey
thank you